los dos candidatos los que tienen
posibilidades de llegar a la presidencia
en bolivia uno de ellos es el candidato
de evo morales el ex ministro de
economía luís arce que tiene una
preferencia que está rondando el 30 por
ciento y que con proyecciones de voto
útil podría llegar al 40 por ciento lo
que le permitiría ganar en primera
vuelta el segundo candidato mejor
posicionado es el ex presidente carlos
mesa que tiene una preferencia electoral
que está alrededor del 22% y que sería
en este caso el beneficiario del voto de
la presidenta ya viene años sin embargo
hay una tercera candidatura de luis
fernando camacho que ha empezado a
emerger en los últimos días y que tiene
básicamente su apoyo popular concentrado
en el departamento de santa cruz y que
podría convertirse en el futuro en el
voto de oro para darle gobernabilidad al
nuevo presidente o que se instalaría
después de las elecciones